es ist ein ganz besonderes elektroauto
denn sie ist nicht nur ein gewöhnliches
elektro sondern zudem auch ein solarauto
der sion gebaut von dem münchner startup
sonne motors für mich das elektroauto
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht doch was kann das solarauto
wirklich wie weit ist es in der
entwicklung und wie nachhaltig ist es
tatsächlich alle wichtigen facts zum
thema jetzt praktisch science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja und vielen dank für den
themenvorschlag aus der whatsapp
beziehungsweise sind messenger community
zitats die größten herausforderung
bestehen darin den missbrauch von
wertvollen und endlichen ressourcen wie
zum beispiel erdöl maßgeblich zu
reduzieren denn erdöl ist ein wichtiger
fossile nicht erneuerbarer rohstoff
unser wichtigstes ziel ist der schutz
der umwelt nur deshalb gibt es so nur
motors überhaupt so heißt es auf der
offiziellen webseite des münchener
start-up fest steht auf der karosserie
des elektroautos sind überall
solarpaneele verbaut
insgesamt sind es 330 monokristalline
silizium-solarzellen aufdach heckklappe
motorhaube und an der seite sie liefern
265 watt pro zelle bei einem
wirkungsgrad von 24% 75 quadratmeter
bilden die zellen insgesamt und sollen
an sonnigen tagen dafür sorgen dass der
solarstrom den akku soweit auflädt dass
er zusätzliche 30 kilometer fahren kann
wenn wolken am himmel sind sind es
immerhin noch 15 kilometer reichweite
die dazu kommt und das ist wirklich eine
menge bisherige entwicklung kam nicht im
entferntesten auch solche werte das
ganze funktioniert tatsächlich wie auf
einem hausdach mit solarmodul das
sonnenlicht selbst elektronen im
silizium frei und liefert sogleich strom
dieser wird dann in die wassergekühlte
lithium ionen batterie die eine
kapazität von 35 bis 45 kilowattstunden
hat im unterboten gespeist wie bei den
meisten anderen elektroautos auch wird
diese beim bremsvorgang aufgeladen falls
die batterien leer sind gibt es einen
haushalts stecker und einen schnell
ladestecker zudem kann es auch von
anderen autos strom zapfen aber es kann
dann 60 auch selbst als mobile
stromspeicher dienen
denn der wagen kann mit der
sonnenenergie nicht nur seinen eigenen
akku laden sondern theoretisch auch
andere elektroautos zudem soll man sich
mit einer app verbinden können falls man
doch einmal liegen bleibt die app zeigt
dann an wo der sion oder andere
elektroautos stehen die strom benötigen
und die anderen leute können dann
starthilfe geben doch die app die soll
noch mehr bieten durch sie können
mitfahrgelegenheiten organisiert werden
oder leute aus der nachbarschaft mit
denen man sich das auto teilen könnte
die können dann gemeinsam darauf
zugreifen und das organisieren und das
finde ich persönlich eine richtig gute
sache ein auto das ab werk auf
carsharing konzepte getrimmt ist zudem
verfügt das solarauto über ein
luftfilter aus moos der feinstaub aus
der luft filtert und schaltete eine
vierköpfige familie soll das voll
betankten auto dann 250 kilometer weit
bringen und für familien und den
mittelstand ist dieses auto auch
vorrangig gedacht so hat es zwar nicht
den luxus eines es doch für ein in dafür
ein instandsetzungs konzept das an
sphären angelehnt ist die fahrer und
fahrerinnen können also problemlos
selbst gemachte und lizenzfrei
herstellbare ersatzteile nach kaufen und
einbauen lassen bisher gibt es aber erst
zwei prototypen die im letzten jahr
durch europa getourt sind
das ist jetzt auch für deutschland
geplant derzeit steckt so ne motors in
der serienentwicklung bis 2019 wollen
sie das solarauto auf die straßen
bringen bis dahin werden die einzelteile
auf resistenz und leistungsfähigkeit
geprüft im sommer also jetzt steht dann
ein großer tüv crashtest an
hier wird vor allem spannend was mit den
solarzellen passiert sie sind mit einer
schicht aus polykarbonat überzogen und
das münchner startup ist zuversichtlich
dass sie unfälle gut überstehen die
schicht sorgt außerdem dafür dass das
auto ziemlich krass resistent ist die
kosten etwa 16.000 euro ohne batterie
die kann man mieten oder kaufen und dann
kommen noch einmal 4000 euro dazu mein
fazit bisher klingt das alles so als sei
das solarauto ein innovativer schritt
hin zu einer tatsächlichen solar aktuell
ektron mobilität die umsetzbar ist teil
der im zusammenspiel mit einer
entsprechenden infrastruktur also mit
solar straßen und radwegen die ihre
eigene energie bereitstellen
und wenn dann noch solarzellen mit einem
höheren wirkungsgrad auf den markt kommt
wird es extra
entspannt schon jetzt hat man am
fraunhofer-institut solarzellen mit
einem wirkungsgrad von mehr als 30
entwickelt ja solar energie wird also
auch für die mobilität immer
interessanter wenn er kein video dazu zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann hättet mich bei whatsapp darum geht
ihr die etwas unzuverlässige abo boxer
auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt und jetzt auch immer mehr
videos dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau wie oder vergessen und wie geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
elektroauto für jeden bis dann bleibt
kann